لقد سمعنا في الساعة الماضية فقط من
وزير الدفاع الإسرائيلي الذي
تلقى أمرًا بحصار كامل على قطاع
غزة واسمحوا لي أن أقتبس هنا اقتباس لا
كهرباء ولا طعام ولا وقود، كل شيء
مغلق هل يخبرك أن
التوغل البري هو
الخشخاش الأمامي الذي سيكون أحد
المؤشرات الرئيسية للتوغل البري، لذا فإن
ما تتحدث عنه هنا في الأساس
هو حقيقة أن كل واحدة من
هذه المناطق هنا ستكون في
جوهرها مستهلكة، لذا فإن ما تفعله هو
أنت تقطع جميع
إمدادات الطاقة، لذا فإن ما لا يقل عن نصف
الكهرباء التي تحصل عليها غزة يتم توفيرها
من إسرائيل أه هذه الحقيقة ذاتها تحد من كل
الأشياء التي يمكن أن يفعلها الغاز أه عندما
يتعلق الأمر بعلم أنها
منطقة مكتظة بالسكان  عندما تنظر إلى
كل ما تراه هنا أه هذا
هنا هو في الواقع أه
المنطقة الحدودية بهذه الطريقة وكل هذه
المنطقة هي غزة، كل هذه
منطقة مزدحمة للغاية ومكتظة بالسكان
أه ربما المنطقة الأكثر كثافة
سكانية على  على الأرض، يوجد حوالي
2 مليون شخص هنا، لذا
ستعاني كل منطقة من هذه المناطق
من نقص الغذاء أه نقص
الكهرباء نقص الصرف الصحي أه في
جوهره هذا ما تفعله اه عندما
تستعد للانتقال إذا
أنت ستقوم بالفعل
بتوغل بري في جوهره، إنهم يفرضون حصارًا
على
غزة من حيث كيفية عمل التوغل البري
هناك، لقد كان هناك
تحفظ حقيقي جدًا للانخراط بشكل كامل في
شيء مثل الجانب العسكري الإسرائيلي
بالضبط  الأسباب التي تجعلك تذكر
مدى الكثافة السكانية فيها أه فقط كيفية
الخروج بمجرد وصولك إلى
حد ما أه ما هي
العناصر الأساسية التي يجب عليهم مراعاتها
قبل القيام بشيء كهذا، لذلك
هناك العديد من الأشياء الأساسية وهذا في
الواقع  نقطة ممتازة، لذلك هناك
شيء فريد في غزة حيث
وصفها الناس بأنها في جوهرها
سجن في الهواء الطلق أه لأنه أه بمجرد دخولهم
لا يمكنهم الخروج الآن،
هذه مبالغة قليلاً لأنه قبل كل
هذه الهجمات كان هناك الكثير  من الأشخاص
من غزة الذين كانوا يعملون في إسرائيل
كان لديهم هذا المعبر الحدودي هنا
هو المعبر الذي كانوا سيستخدمونه للدخول
والعمل في وظائف يومية في إسرائيل أه ولكن أه
كل هذا مغلق الآن ولذا فإن إحدى
الميزات الفريدة التي لديهم  ما يجب
مراعاته هو أن هؤلاء الأشخاص لا يمكنهم
الخروج من أي شيء يحدث هنا،
وهذا في جوهره محظور
هنا وهذه الحقيقة بالذات أه تجعل من
الصعب حقًا على الإسرائيليين الدخول
لأنه عندما تنظر إلى كل ما هو
مختلف  أه المناطق هنا كلها أه
شوارع ضيقة جدًا جميع المناطق المبنية
مع عدد قليل جدًا من المناطق الزراعية على
الأقل في هذا الجزء من غزة وهذا
يجعل الأمر صعبًا لأن ما
تتعامل معه هنا هو ما يعرف
بحرب المدن سيكون الأمر
صعبًا حقًا  لكي يصل الناس إلى هنا أه
لتتحرك القوات الإسرائيلية في المباني
حول الزوايا حول الغرف
يجب أن تكون استخباراتهم التكتيكية
دقيقة للغاية خاصة عندما
يتعلق الأمر بأي جهود لمحاولة إنقاذ
الرهائن وسيكون أه
لحظة حرجة بالنسبة للإسرائيليين،
سيتعين عليهم أن يقرروا بالضبط كيف
يريدون القيام بذلك وما هي الأشياء الأخرى التي
يمكنهم القيام بها من أجل تحقيق ذلك